Oh welcome to you on the first live holy
workout sessions together and so I'm
just gonna start the timer because I do
not have any room with me right here I
don't have any anybody help me basically
but you know what I thought that you
stay active from the comfort of your
home let me know in the comments below
which country are you from and how long
has it been since the lobster so in
Malaysia it has already been 20 days can
you imagine that
oh it's crazy but you know what I
actually enjoyed my more and more okay
let's get started okay let's get started
and today's workout is keep stripping
crap so it's going to be a mess and also
five focus so guys to get up for this
two hopper to the next and do this
workout together
I don't want you to be watching me doing
this workout I want you to jump in and
join me with this or a gasps okay right
let's stop in boom box again step in the
pot with your toes
I want you to just be here nice deep
squat wherever you are
good morning good evening let's wait
okay so give me a nice deep squat
remember to always push your butt back
check up and stand tall and not just
reach your hands up reach good
Rita feel your back in stretch up feel
your muscles waking up very good few
more one more and give okay give me some
like this alright so step angel you're
next now take a step back now with us
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
one more on each side
right yeah right left that I am now
thanks here okay just a little bit
stretches for the cord and don't just
squeeze just warming up the core okay
because we are also going to do it
caught learner go good
so just tweet right of me to your elbow
keep going very good okay you can kind
of reaching your knee to the elbow
that's why everybody's keeping nice I
really enjoy before workouts it's really
keeping me happy and I feel like I have
a flush to go somewhere else okay now
just shake it out and just tweeting side
to side okay okay there will be a total
of two around today so four is relic
just integral for Israel then we need a
total of seven x-fighters and each one
now is going to be for 45 seconds long
15 seconds pressing - okay so the first
workout it's been three days what enzyme
squeak ready let's go squat and we open
inside only 45 seconds I'm going to
really be real gentle and we're gonna do
the workout what remember you see about
that and twist push it back enters nice
there you go amazing job how much you
meditate let's do it work out together
[Music]
okay
it's me to really work on in advice as
long as the class it's good of you only
the middle of a challenge who's
unconscious then what were you doing it
all brings your wife you clap to all the
name is okay good
if you just burn feel the burn and I'm
gonna right now nice and easy
really pollution fun
okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so making sure you don't take them ah
very good
yeah when it's one and
okay okay nice work okay let's do this
straight let's play using your hands
give me a shot we got
it's better and nowhere and now just
need you and we're going to move on to
round number two right can you hear me
really really clearly I just want to
make sure
okay before everyone the second second
okay
it's all working on thighs glutes and
your ass you want a solid ass okay very
good
stop cuddling is that everyone's do you
doing okay
echo is it okay right now it's our
veteran equina yeah all right can
everybody hear me okay let's go squat
and twist squat entries nice keep going
twice okay choose your option choose
your intensity keep going nice second
round
you still don't work out let's give it
our best
they rest it out in and out
squat job okay everyone stay with me
okay it is not that hot you can do this
all right let's go stop boy come in and
remember to point your toes up when it
turns out touch and I came back down
with the 4k blow just ending from your
waist
[Music]
this is to top in ah okay evil won't
work out when I'm not sweaty
okay
that's ready to get down to the core now
let's work on your strong you know I
love this thing
I'm from Nike that if you have a funny
you are
so each and every one of us exactly I'm
sure you all agree okay hit reach market
so de minimis right left right left
it's gonna challenge you but it metal
challenge you you haven't change you so
let's stay together let's stay strong
last two workouts we're done okay
let's duplicate and just relax okay
who's excited look this is your final
workout okay final we're not so no
excuses
EMS I want you to do the burn on your
core all right
you have an amazing workout okay this is
a short running times workout it's to
really work on your core right your legs
and your glutes so remember that
movement when you mirela in the world
please stay safe stay active at home and
just look after yourself your family the
community and this world that we're
living in right now all right all right
so before I let you go let's just do a
quick two minute stretch so stop
indication traumatic take your right
knee pull up and what you do is put your
weight forward okay and really do the
stretch on your left hip flexor and I
read arms up feel the strength in your
back and hold there and I'll just drop
it and squeeze okay in your back swing
not lunch for don't sit up straight
check your posture and Chris okay and
move and I'll just straighten your legs
and feel the stretch my hamstrings away
and now really bad opposite side nothing
father
[Music]
enjoy this light workout session if you
do want to watch more like breakout
sessions with me let me know in the
comments below which funny person I
focus on do you want more strength
training do you want how do you break
that yeah just let me know and I want to
work out with you guys and I will see
you next time all the best don't do also
check out my 21-day stay home workout
clearly designed that just for you guys
to encourage you to motivate you to stay
active oh and you also check out my
fingers at fault you know
on the Excel or Google Play because you
will enjoying tons of keep singing
forgot beats it's really also workout
and I was feeling very beginner and I'm
gonna replay comic as well see you guys
okay yeah I'm just gonna click the
finish button
finish village ha let me end my stream
ok let me know which country you're from
how long has your lockdown bin how are
you coping from home and if everything
is okay let me know okay guys okay